hi i'm beth patel
i'm a senior developer at mayo clinic in
the clinical genomics laboratory
and i'm excited to share with you an
overview
of some resources that i find
particularly
helpful in facilitating cancer-variance
interpretation
i have nothing to disclose
the objectives of this talk are to help
you understand the types of resources
that are available for variant
interpretation
to review some of the more prominent
cancer genome interpretation resources
and to understand the landscape of
interconnectivity between these
resources
and what that means for our field
so there when you're looking at large
assays with high throughput there are
automatically
processed portions of these assays that
lead to this bottleneck of variant
interpretation
so right now we're able to
automatically process annotate and
filter
variants using bioinformatics pipelines
and algorithms
but um ultimately this
bottleneck occurs when the human element
needs to be integrated
to this workflow and so that person
needs to actually
interpret all of that data that comes
down to this
to the bottleneck in the interpretation
pipeline and that person is responsible
for putting together a report for
the clinicians i find it particularly
helpful
to understand the difference between
data and knowledge
or information that you would find in a
database or data portal
versus information you would find in a
knowledge base
so i like to think of data as what you
would see in the results section of a
manuscript
and this might include statistics that
are derived
algorithmically from large data sets for
instance the top 20 mutations
in a specific cancer type knowledge on
the other hand
i'd like to think of as more of the
discussion section of the manuscript
where we're critically processing the
data for clinical relevance
often knowledge bases contain
information that's populated by
dedicated curation staff or expert crowd
sourcing
and these uh these resources are often
driven
primarily by scientific literature
and then there's this area the gray area
in the middle of the screen
that is bridging the gap so you can use
data to automatically make some
inferences
about what that might mean in a clinical
setting and so
databases often have really great
visualizations
and that can help you understand what
that data means
so these might include a 3d structure of
the proteins that you can use
to understand where your variant lies in
the protein structure
relative to maybe a drug target you can
create
survival plots with some resources or
mutation grids where you can look at
co-mutations
some databases incorporate pathogenicity
scores and algorithms and some
have available informatics workflows
that you can use to help
classify variants
so this slide is meant to just summarize
the different kinds of resources that
are available and the different kinds of
data that are available
so we have literature search engines
like um for instance genomic mastermind
or pubmed
google scholar we have clinical
experience databases like clinvar
cancer variant databases like cosmetic
or c bioportal
and silicone predictors like swift or
polygon
cancer variant knowledge bases like
civic or also kb
clinical trials resources population
databases
like nomad or a thousand genomes
or cytogenetic knowledge bases like the
middlemen database or
atlas and what's happening in our field
right now
is that we have a lot of this
aggregation activity
where a lot of different data types are
now being kind of packaged together
or being connected with each other
through api or
citing each other in the resources
and so this happens in a couple
different forms
it happens in the form of publicly
available or commercial products that
are now integrating
these different types of data into a
single piece of software
this happens by harmonizing knowledge so
i'll talk in a little bit about a group
that is um
nations from several different resources
and then
standardizing the annotation so it's
more readable
and you can search those that
information with
a single query and then also you have
molecular tumor boards
which um different people can use
different resources
and bring that knowledge back into the
tumor board either
in person or virtually or however you do
tumor boards these days
and so um in the next several slides
we'll be reviewing
a number of different resources and i've
coded them with these icons for
ease of recognition so some of these
resources have information at the gene
or variant level
some have information at the
cytogenetics level
some contain evidence for clinical
relevance
of each variant some contain
exemplary visualization tools
some are manually curated by experts in
our field
we've talked a little bit about a
knowledge base versus a data
data portal or database and i'll make
those distinctions on these slides as
well
some resources have data available for
download
and some resources have api available
which helps you connect these resources
in an automated way to other
applications
so cosmetic or the catalog of somatic
mutations in cancer is the first
resource that we'll go over cosmetic
has so much functionality it's really
hard to summarize this in just a couple
slides
so um it's really fun to go and play
around
in cosmic because they're always coming
up with something new
and they're they're really a leader
in thematic
data so this is developed and curated at
the welcome center institute in
cambridge sharer uk
there are currently over 10 million
mutations
curated on this database and they're
currently on version 93
of the database you can just imagine the
amount of effort that
has gone into curating and building this
repository
they have a very famous um list
called the cancer gene census you've
probably heard of it or
heard of people using it in different
ways they also have a cancer mutation
census which i'll go into
in the next slide um cosmic 3d is a
great tool and this is where you can see
a
3d model of the protein also there are
mutational signatures available on
cosmic
annotations across genome builds
so if you have data from hg 19 and 38
you are able to see both of those
annotations there are downloads for
licensed users
and brand new x cosmic or actionability
data
that you can download with the license
as well
in this panel i wanted to show the
utility of the cancer browser
and in this case i've filtered by tissue
sub
tissue and histology so
we filtered by the tissue being
a central nervous system brain tissue
and this is a atypical teratoday tumor
and we see our top 20 genes that are
mutated in this cancer type and
generating a list like this can be very
useful when you're running quality
control
on a panel or a gene list that may be
created in-house
and you wanted to make sure that you
capture a lot of the genes
that are clinically relevant
are often mutated in that tumor type and
so
um this might prompt additional
literature searches or investigations
into genes that maybe
you didn't consider initially
and i really wanted to show kind of on a
gene level
what cosmic can do so i've i've had here
uh the able1 gene and the cosmic 3d
model
of the protein also there are several
genes that are annotated for hallmarks
of cancer
and the hallmarks of cancer really kind
of biological functions
of cancer and the genes that are
annotated
for the hallmarks of cancer are marked
as either promoting or suppressing these
biological activities
and then i i also wanted to highlight
the mutation census so the mutation
census actually catalogs the
all of the mutations that are in cosmic
database
in a in a kind of special way here
so the mutation significance which i've
shown kind of on the bottom of the
screen here classifies
uh variance in two different um
into different tiers or significance
levels
or for those mutations
and also in the mutation census are
clinvar
entries nomad frequencies evolution
probability
frequency of the occurrence of the
mutation in cosmetic
and conserved sequences
the next database i'm going to go over
is c
bio portal and c bio portal is developed
at memorial sloan kettering
and hosted by the center for molecular
oncology
cbio portal houses data from lots of
large studies
including tcga and many others
the information in cbio portal
is easy to view and easy to stratify
so i really encourage people to play
around and see by the portal
especially if you have like a a diseased
interest
and um work on uh
manipulating that data within this
interface because it's really pretty
cool
um also sea bio portal in the last year
has posted
uh several tutorials on youtube
so you can go check those out and um
fifa portal for years has allowed us to
visualize our own data
as well um which i'll show on the next
slide
so on the bottom panel here i have
looked
into a specific gene and
when you search for a gene and they're
in their quick search function
you can see the alteration frequency
and also the alteration type present
in several of these large
studies so it really gives you a sense
of the importance of that gene
and in what cancer types it is altered
so i did mention that you can visualize
your data in cbio portal
and one of the ways to do that is by
using the mutation mapper
and what the mutation mapper does is
allows you to visualize your data
in a lollipop plot like this one
and then the other way to visualize your
data in c via portal is by using the
anchor grid
and the optical grid is really nice if
you want to stratify your data based on
molecular specific molecular profiles or
if you want to view
co-mutations this is a really helpful
way to do that
after kb is the knowledge-based partner
to see
bioportal and they're both posted out of
memorial sloan kettering
also kb is probably most well known for
its annotation
using evidence levels for therapeutic
significance but recently they have
included
evidence levels for diagnostic and
prognostic evidence as well
the prognostic evidence is currently
available
for hematologic malignancies only but
solid tumors will be coming
i'm sure fairly soon also if you would
want to annotate your
your own lab data using alka kb
annotations there is a way to do that
as well and so at the bottom of the
screen
i have shown the home page for ankle kb
and it's really pretty slick you can
toggle between
the therapeutic evidence levels
diagnostic levels
and prognostic levels to see the
representation
of these data types in the knowledge
base and you can also do a quick search
for a gene name or disease type
right in in that search bar if you
search for atms
you'll get the bar graph that's in the
top right
of the screen and you can see the
percent of samples with alterations
in atm across tumor types which is also
very helpful
and i really wanted to include this
slide as well this is available
on kbe website as well
but i think it's really helpful for
those of us who work in a clinical
setting
to be able to align these evidence
levels with the amp esco
guidelines so this is really handy that
they've kind of made those connections
for
us
so the next resource i'm going to go
over is civic
or the clinical interpretation of
variance in cancer
it's hosted out of the mcdonald genome
institute
at washu in st louis they have
a really great curation team
at civic but they also include
crowdsourcing from experts in our field
they have several youtube tutorials that
not only teach you to
use civic but also teach you how to
contribute if that's something you're
interested in
they've recently had a key collaboration
established with the clinton somatic
cancer
domain working group and
what this means is that this working
group from clinton
will actually populate
the civic database with their findings
and so i think that this is a really
cool
collaboration that that will make sure
that a lot of the prominence and that
experience
are in in civic
also they've had a recent integration
with protein paint
which is part of the st juice pecan data
portal that i'll talk about on the next
slide
so i want to show a couple of
screenshots from civic
i find the browse function to be really
helpful
in civic and so when you go into the
browse function you can type
into any of the search bars
towards the top of the table here i've
typed in coenzio carcinoma
and what populates below are all of the
variants
that are associated with
polentiocarcinoma
in acidic so this is a really helpful
way to
again kind of do that cross-checking um
qc review
of variants in a specific cancer type
and there are several other ways to use
this as well
and um also in civic one of the really
cool
things about civic is how they display
evidence and so this is one of the
evidence tables
displayed for an egfr amplification
and so in the table you'll see four rows
and these
represent four different pieces of
primary literature
and the icons in the table are coded for
for recognition so you can see
um this first line actually means that
it's a course of poor
prognosis and then the next three lines
you'll see
uh drugs listed in the drug column and
the table and these are
related to more predictive or
therapeutic implications
um but when you actually click on one of
the rows or one of the pieces of
evidence the panel below this
populates where you can see a one to two
sentence summary
of this piece of evidence and link out
to pubmed to
make your own assertions which i always
recommend
the pediatric cancer data portal is
developed from
saint jude's children's research
hospital
and um i think that they're a real
leader in
visualizations and just visualizing
large sets of data in general um
in addition to the visuals we'll go over
today
i wanted to make aware that this group
also
has some publicly available
bioinformatics workflows including
the pecan pie or the pathogenicity
information exchange
which will classify variants into
different metal levels
so on the right side of this slide at
the top
is a representation of all of the cases
that are
cataloged in the pcan data portal
and they're stratified by disease type
so the yellow is solid tumor
the blue is brain tumor and the red is
hematologic malignancies and then
different subtypes
of within those categories also on the
home page you'll see a word cloud of
different gene names
and you'll see how frequently these
genes are altered
within those disease types kind of
color-coded the same as
the pie chart above
another really powerful visualization
tool in pecan data portal is protein
paint and that's shown below the only
difference between protein paint
and genome paint is within protein paint
you'll only
see the mutations that fall within
exons or coating regions for fusion
[Music]
with genome paint you start to see some
of those more
intron related mutations and you'll
actually look at
a larger transcript of the
gene itself so below is the 801 gene
by um by protein paint
so you can see the lollipop plot there
you also see buttons that connect
um not just the data from keycam data
portal but also
cosmic clinvar and civic which i
referred to
earlier so probably
uh some of my favorite things about this
graph
are that you can see the domains
that are color coded on the protein
itself
and on the bottom rectangle of the
protein and then also if you
click on a fusion
you'll actually see a representation of
the pertinent fusion and understand
which domains from both fusion partners
are
in the fusion transcript in the actual
fusion that was observed
so the jackson clinical knowledge base
and this one actually the other
animation went a little too quick but we
can talk through it
um this is based out of the jackson
laboratory and there's several different
license there are a couple different
licensing tiers i wanted to mention
here there's the ckb core which is the
free license to jack ckb
and this includes kind of the basic um
you know primary driver genes
for cancer and a lot of the therapeutic
information
that it's in jack ckb the boost
really ups the functionality it has a
larger gene list
that the knowledge base covers
and then also adds some of these more
interactive
visual um kind of stunning pieces
within jeff ckb and then the third
license
that we can see right now is a ckg flex
and the ckb flex allows for data
downloads
and kind of more uh interactivity
between
um the ckb and your own lab applications
and then in um in addition
to a lot of more therapeutic
detailed information that you find in
jax ckb
they have this concept of a molecular
profile
that is unique to ckb
and what this means is that you can
actually
look at information
regarding not just one variant but a
combination of variants
and so in one of the panels on this
slide you'll see that we have searched
for an owl rearrangement
and a met amplification and we were able
to
find um information on
this molecular profile and linking to
two pieces of primary literature and
then in the front of the slide it's a
sunburst spot that's available
through ckb boost and this is
annotating or a representation of
all the annotations in jack's cbd
um in relation to the alk genes
so you can further filter your search
through an interactive sunburst plot
which is exciting
the next resource i'll go over is the
molecular oncology almanac
and this is from the broad ending the
farmer or
dana farber sorry and you can search by
biomarker
cancer type level of predictive
multiplication or therapy
and the level of predictive implication
might be my favorite thing about this
because you're so
easily able to identify the pieces of
evidence that make
different alterations a tier one
event so you can you can find your
pieces of evidence that
that make a gene um make a gene and
therapy combination
fda approved like you see on this bottom
panel the top line
you'll see that tsd1 oncogenic mutations
with upper alignment there's
there's a link to the evidence saying
that that is an fda approved therapy
for tsd one oncogenic mutations which is
really really helpful
so the middleman database of chromosome
aberrations
and gene fusions in cancer is funded by
the national cancer institute
and a couple of swedish cancer societies
um it's supported by the institute for
assistance biology cancer genomics
cloud and that's one of the few
cytogenetics
related databases knowledge bases out
there
and so on this database you can search
over
70 000 cases that are curated from the
primary literature
and you can download the entire database
or you can download results from the
search
also i've heard that there's some
visualization coming soon so
stay tuned um probably my favorite
search function within middlemen
is the recurrent chromosome aberration
search
where you can search for a chromosome
ban or a particular
imbalance and it will search the
literature and you'll find
cases with that same alterations
and you can link to the primary
literature you can see the karyotype for
those cases along with
the diagnosis or morphology so it's a
pretty cool
resource
phenomenon mastermind is a literature
search
tool that uses natural language
processing to mine
and prioritize over 30 million articles
and over
two million supplemental data sets there
are two licenses with this product as
well there's a basic license which
allows you to run a simple query
or a professional license which adds a
lot of
functionality and a lot of kind of more
in-depth searches
so you can explore um associations which
i'll go into in the next slide
or a focus view in the pro version so
below
um in the piano below you'll see a
graph with a bunch of circles in it and
each circle represents
a publication and on the y-axis
is the citations per journal and on the
x-axis
is the year and the size of the circle
is corresponds to the impact factor of
the journal
so this is for the x and two genes
this next graph is also on
their user interface and it allows you
to refine your search
to a particular gene domain
or a particular residue within that gene
which is pretty helpful
and i've mentioned that there's a new
association function
in genomic mastermind for the probe
version of mastermind and what you can
do here is really adjust your
search criteria to include
so many things including csvs
therapies diseases variants and then you
can
look at all of your evidence once you've
kind of taken all the pieces that you
want to refine in your search
and i really wanted to touch on a little
bit of data harmonization
by talking about the variant
interpretation for cancer consortium
this group is a driver project
and part of the global alliance for
genomics and health
and what this group did was they took
several different prominent knowledge
bases
and took the elements from these
knowledge bases
and annotated them similarly so you
could
query multiple knowledge bases with one
search and this
is really important the the need for
this
came arose from interrogation
of all the variants within these
knowledge bases and we
found that um
you know most variants were only
annotated
in either one or two knowledge bases and
only eight variants
were annotated across all of these
knowledge bases so that was really
surprising
so when i first gave an iteration of
this talk
back in 2017 um
different uh knowledge bases and
databases were starting
to make connections with each other
through api
or through data sharing or by
referencing
each other in the knowledge bases
themselves
and over the last couple years we've
seen these connections become more
intricate
and become more involved with each other
so we've seen
more integration between different
databases and knowledge bases and
aggregation activity
just the integration so we're not there
yet
but what we're hoping for
is this ideal state where a user
will be able to define it what they want
in a comprehensive resource
and be able to tap into everything with
one
interface instead of having to go into
10 or 12 different resources
to work up a variant
so in summary cancer genome
interpretation
and research require the right resources
and the landscape of genomic resources
is constantly
evolving and connecting with each other
it's a really exciting
time for genomic knowledge basis and
databases
and we can all benefit from the
collaborations that are being made
and i highly recommend if you have the
bandwidth or if you have the interest
to connect with groups like vic or
clindgen
or one and any of the knowledge based
groups
to um help further their efforts because
it's really it's really a neat
field to be in and then looking into the
future we can expect to see
a more connected landscape of resources
aggregation activity
and just overall comprehensiveness of
these resources
as they become more connected and then
we'll also
um look forward to seeing further
development
and incorporation of things like natural
language processing machine
learning artificial intelligence into
these resources as well
so i have a lot of people to acknowledge
thank you to the laboratories
committee for inviting me to come talk
today
thanks to the genomics of oncology
annotation team at mayo clinic
for supporting this work and really
driving these efforts
also thanks to the cancer genomics
consortium for
for their ongoing support and
collaboration as well and all of the
knowledge-based experts that have
contributed to my understanding and my
really nice experience with all of these
resources
so thanks so much for listening to me
today
um feel free to email me with any
questions find me on twitter or linkedin
as well
and have a great time during
this virtual event thanks so much